so our agenda today I want to first talk
about cloud adoption statistics I mean I
think many people really underestimate
what's going on with cloud now I want to
highlight that because that talks about
why it's so important for the
organization why cloud computing is you
know the one of the big very biggest
trends going on in IT and one of them a
trend that is going to be only growing
over time so we'll talk about cloud
adoption statistics then I'm talking
about cloud application deployment
patterns one of the great benefits of
cloud is that it enables and accelerates
application deployment the question is
what's the right model to use for that
in terms of architecture so this is
going to be about the process of putting
applications in the cloud I assign them
and so forth not in a very deep
technical level but more as general sort
of you might call them deployment
patterns then we'll move on to building
cloud skills as i mentioned i said we
talked about that and sort of that
importance of them and how to go about
that training organizational skill and
so forth and then we'll have time for
questions and i hope you'll submit
questions chip did I I was listening but
I didn't catch he said how they should
submit the questions but I think there's
a chat box or something that they could
submit to you is that right that's
correct they should actually use the
questions module rather than cha and I
will go ahead and will queue them up in
the questions module and we'll circle
back to those at the end of the
presentation clearly chip is the Guru of
the webinar stuff i'm sort of barely
acquainted but anyway yeah submit them
in the questions and that way we can you
know they can be forward to me and i can
address them as we go along or as we
finish up so let's talk about cloud
adoption what's going on that and many
people really underestimate what's going
on in cloud computing how powerful
trinity's but here I've got some
statistics so just three weeks ago maybe
four weeks ago amazon announced its AWS
Amazon Web Services numbers and it did
2.8 billion dollars within eight of us
for the quarter with a fifty-eight
percent growth rate so compared to july
two thousand five
it said we're nearly sixty percent
larger and that's been pretty consistent
that growth rate it's it's hovering
somewhere around sixty to seventy
percent and they did 2.8 billion dollars
that means they're on a run rate of
something on the order of 11 12 billion
dollars for the year and really this
level of within the technology industry
and maybe in every industry that level
of growth at that scale at that size
company is really unprecedented I mean
sixty percent growth on a 12 billion
dollar run rate 11 or 12 billion dollar
run rate is really unprecedented at most
businesses and that shows the power of
what they're offering and how much user
adoption is moving to cloud computing
and so you know very impressive numbers
amazon is clearly the leader in this
space but it's by no means the only
significant player in this cloud
computing area Microsoft has its own
offering called Azure and it talks about
its cloud numbers but it's hard to
really discern what is the computing
part of that sort of comparable to what
amazon offers and what of what of that
number that they announced is technology
like office 365 which are very powerful
offerings but aren't really germane to
IT organizations who are going to place
applications straight remain for you
know running email or you know doing
documents whoever it might be but really
what we want to talk about here is IT
organizations taking advantage of cloud
computing as a way to deliver
applications so it's kind of difficult
because they announced a general number
but I've gone back through kind of
extrapolated correlated interpolated all
of the estimates I've seen for measure
and a conservative number is five
hundred million dollars per quarter but
with about a hundred and twenty percent
growth so in other words you know even
though Amazon's growth rate is extremely
impressive as yours is you know very
very high in higher than eight of us as
you might might expect autumns on a
smaller base but that's about a two
billion dollar run rate growing in a
hundred percent
+ per year so obviously quite impressive
and Google Google is you know probably
is considered really the third of the
big three but it's sort of the smallest
of the big three it's its numbers are
unannounced and it's lumped into the
general google numbers which you know is
mostly advertising so it's hard to
really know what that number is but it's
widely assumed it probably less than a
billion dollars a year growing pretty
rapidly I think it's fair say that
Google has not really focused on cloud
computing over the past three or four
years it's had the offering it's talked
about it but it hasn't been a core focus
for you for the company or the
organization but I my sense is a year
year and a half ago they stay really
started to say this is a serious area we
should have a strong presence here we
can deliver a tremendous amount of value
what do we do about that and one of the
things they did was they went and hired
a woman named Diane Greene and Diane
Greene is the founder or co-founder I
should say of VMware which is you know
everybody's for VMware very powerful
infrastructure player and she has come
in and really is spearheading their
effort to become a much bigger player in
cloud computing and they've started
really hire very strongly across across
the board within Google and they're
putting forward a lot of emphasis on
enterprises which is probably true
meaning for everybody in this audience
so Google is you might say an understudy
at this point but ambition to get onto
the main stage and that's you know we
will expect to see them coming forward
in the future as well so these big three
you know and and just by way of
comparison to make to really bring out
how how important or how big initiative
or start a trend this is vmware which is
you know one of the biggest
infrastructure players in the entire
industry by comparison it did 1.7
billion dollars last quarter you know
not a bad quarter but it's only seeing
six percent growth so really it's it's
almost barely growing and so you can see
that this
the trend toward cloud adoption is
enormous growing growing much faster
than the rest of the industry it's a big
trend so now that we sort of have you
know kind of a point-in-time kind of
thing let's look at where this is going
to go this is projection on AWS national
revenues over the next five years and
you'll see why I've used this five year
period of the next slide but given those
kind of growth rates assuming that
Amazon is going to grow at something
like fifty percent a year and Asher will
continue at its hundred percent per year
over the next five years we can see that
just those two are going to be nearly a
hundred billion dollars in revenue I
mean that's an enormous enormous amount
of spin that's going to go into cloud
computing and that represents the
enormous number of applications being
deployed so really this is becoming i
call it the computing substrate of the
IT industry and really reflects i got
involved cloud computing probably a
decade ago when i first got exposed to
it as a result of writing my book
virtualization for dummies and when i
saw it a database is infrastructure
service it it just powerfully impacted
me i said that is going to be the
computing platform of the future and now
we're really starting to see that that
really take hold so 100 billion dollars
by 2020 there's going to be a very
powerful powerful trend what does that
mean you know from the from the user
side so we've just talked about the
providers and it's clear they're
experiencing Norma's growth enormous
adoption enormous revenues let's talk
about what it looks like from the user
side
jpmorgan which is a you know a very
large financial institution does a lot
of animal research within industries and
so forth did a survey of 200 large
enterprise CIOs with an average height
easement of six hundred million dollars
so you can see that these are very large
now that that six hundred million
dollars was the mean and that ranged
everywhere from from organization
spending ten to twenty million dollars
to organizations spending several
billion dollars in IT but the average
was Center me so really reflective of
what you might call the fortune 2000 and
what came across was an enormous amount
of cloud adoption over the next five
years what they asked them what
percentage of your applications are
currently deployed within cloud
providers amazon asier rule and what
percentage do you expect by 2020 and as
you can see from this chart what they
said was today we have about sixteen
percent of our applications are deployed
in cloud computing environments but 2020
we're going to have forty-one percent of
our applications are going to be
operating in cloud computing
environments now so the first
observation is that's dramatic growth
you know that's getting on toward half
of the entire application portfolio
operating in cloud environments so if he
ran typical enterprise IT organization a
large enterprise IT organization you're
going to see something like almost half
of your application portfolio operating
cloud environments you know the key
question is that I took away from that
is ok you asked up to 2020 what happens
to 2000 21 22 23 24 in other words does
this level off at forty-one percent or
is this just you know a way station
three forty-one percent in 2020 but by
2025 it might be sixty percent or
seventy percent and I guess you know
from my perspective
from my perspective there's nothing
that's going to top that off at
forty-one percent that should happen to
be you know a question what are you
going to be doing in five years and
we're likely to see an increased growth
in cloud deployments so it's likely that
the future of IT is largely cloud-based
and in ten years time this number might
be something like seventy five percent
so really that's a dominant reality for
enterprise IT organizations so let's
talk about the implications of this so
first I think I just said it you know
there's a massive shift to public cloud
deployment the future of IT is going to
be very largely cloud centered I would
assert this is not universally shared
but I would assert that the public club
is going to end up representing
virtually all net new applications so of
that whole hundred percent application
portfolio that forty-one percent of it
is going to be residing in cloud
environments you know that's that's
going to represent some amount of
transfer I'm going to take my current
applications and migrate them to the
cloud for you know any number of reasons
but it's also going to be all the new
ones I believe you know probably ninety
percent of all net new applications are
going to go into cloud environments so
when Enterprise IT organizations sit
down and say okay we're going to plan a
new application we're going to plan a
new offering of a new set of
functionality one of the questions
always is you know where are we going to
put it are we going to put it inside our
own data center or some data center
environment that we control it at colo
environment are we going to put it in a
cloud or something like that and i
believe that over the next five years
the nearly universal answer to that
question about where will we put this
new application will be yeah we're going
to put in the cloud environment we're
going to put it up in a public cloud
environment
and the implication of that is that
really cloud computing must be a core
confidence for enterprise IT
organizations so you know five years ago
a lot of cloud adoption was by
developers or so-called shadow IT in
other words you know business units
saying you know I mean that the the
phrase was always you know I t is the
Department of know you know whenever we
go to IT all we hear is why kiss-off
can't get done sorgen business units
would say well we're just going to go do
it ourselves and we'll put it up in
Amazon or spring that so-called shadow
IT so meaning tactical kinds of adoption
we're going to put this particular
application up there or something like
that what these stats were imply is that
this is going to move from a tactical
adoption to a strategic adoption meaning
cloud computing will no longer be a an
individual choice for an individual
application it will be a general choice
for the entire application fleet so you
know that means that cloud computing
must be a core competence for enterprise
IT organizations now what I'd like to do
is say okay let's you know I I hope this
is provided a perspective that says you
know cloud is a really big deal you know
it's a it's a core capability for
enterprise IT organizations virtually
all of your new applications are going
to go to cloud environments and an
increasing percentage of your current
application portfolio so an obvious
question is law so what did the Zap
cases look like when they go into cloud
environments how am I going to deploy
them what's the writer or the right
architectural patterns and so I want to
talk about that for a few minutes well
the first is what I call lift and shift
or relieves widely shared term which is
basically you take an existing
application as is or you might take your
existing application development plan
pattern your current architectural
patterns your current architectural
designs and you use them as is for cloud
environment
so let's talk about the benefits of the
drawbacks of that approach well one is
if you have an existing application and
you transfer it as is you don't have to
really do a lot of reengineering you
just say i'm going to pick it up i'm
going to move it in a cloud environment
make the adjustment to use Amazon's
virtual machines instead of my own
virtual machines my own virtual vm
environment i'm going to use the same
database i'm going to run my run the
database myself i'm going to manage all
the infrastructure and so forth well
that doesn't require a lot of
reengineering which is very attractive
so you can make that migration you know
fairly quickly it can be as I said next
bullet point it can be fairly fast so
this isn't a sort of a you know two-year
process you can might do it relatively
quickly and it doesn't require a
tremendous amount of staff Reese killing
obviously have to learn the fundamentals
and using the cloud environment but you
know your sort of core patterns of I'm
going to win you know run this virtual
machine and Amazon the way I run them
internally I'm going to install code the
same way I'm going to use the same
management tools I'm going to monitor it
the same way I'm going to update it the
same same in the same fashion so forth
you don't have to do a lot of Reese
killing but I don't want to say that
this is the best way to do it or the
only way to do it for sure or the
perfect way there are some challenges
around this one of them is you often
have poor application resilience you
know one of the general benefits of
cloud computing environments is they can
be much more resilient provide better up
time that on-premise and that's because
of things like they have you know giant
server fleets to a particular server
goes down it's very easy to get another
one it's not like an on-premise
environment where when a server breaks
it's like oh we have to get maintenance
in and until that's in you know where
the applications down or if we want to
transfer to another server we've either
got to buy one in or we've got to find
one that's free that's set for et cetera
so you commonly can get higher
resilience in the infrastructure in
cloud environments but oftentimes
applications are not designed for that
so you
what you really want is redundancy and
failover let me talk about that on next
slide but if you use a lift and shift
environment they're lifted shift pattern
oftentimes your applications are not
really designed to do that very easily
so you often find what I've heard
complaints by many organizations is they
think I'm going to take this application
that i built and operated in my own
environment I'm going to move to the
cloud and magically it's been going to
the availability is going to be higher
the downtime is going to be reduced its
to be fantastic because cloud is more
reliable than my own environment and
what they find is yeah the clouds more
reliable but my application is doesn't
really take advantage of that isn't
designed for that and so I don't really
have better up time so one drawback is
you know you may not release experience
better application resilience another is
that oftentimes the operational patterns
that are perfect or perfect make perfect
sense for a premise environment what can
end result in higher cloud costs and let
me give you an example that in a
on-premise environment let's say you
have an applica report you run twice a
month and its report that you know give
you some statistics on inventory or
something like that or days outstanding
of invoices whatever it might be well it
makes perfect sense if you bought a
server to run that bad application to
just turn it up and let it run all the
time I mean you bought the server you're
not going to pay any extra for having it
running it's going to be up and
available you know and you don't have
any problems with sort of getting some
operational somebody on the operation
staff to bring it out of quiz mode and
bring it up and make it available and so
forth so you just turn up and you let it
run it makes perfect sense well in a
cloud environment for every hour that
that thing is running you're paying for
it running even if you only use it for
four hours a month and so what can
happen is you can end up having pretty
high operational costs compared to what
you might do if you operate your
application differently or designed to
be operated differently so you can
experience high cloud costs and
organizations
sometimes experience what you might call
sticker shock they get the bill they go
wow I didn't expect it to be that much I
thought cloud was so cheap well it can
be if you operate your applications
properly so you know high cloud costs
we'll talk a little bit about how to
address that in the next slide and then
there's little opportunity for
competitive advantage what I mean by
that is one of the great benefits of
cloud computing is it enables you to
design and operate applications
differently it's easier to integrate
different kinds of services and so forth
but if you just use the same old
application that you built on premise
it's harder to get competitive advantage
and that's prickly true if you're really
running a kind of an industry standard
package you know if your ERP system is
just like everybody else is well you're
not going to get much competitive
advantage so there are benefits to doing
this lift and shift but it it has some
drawbacks or some shortcomings let's
talk about the next pattern you might
use so you can refactor your
applications and really what that means
is let me take better advantage of the
way that cloud computing environment
operates and the services it provides
and redesign my application to align
with that and you know one common
example is a move from vertical scaling
to horizontal scaling typically within
most environments if you sort of say
gosh you know we scope this to be a
thousand users but now we're getting two
thousand users how do we you know
support that load the answer is x bigger
computer vertical scaling well you know
very commonly that 1000 to 2000 might
happen once a week or once a day or once
a month whatever it might be or it might
be you know sort of infrequent but
occurring well you can use what's called
horizontal scaling rather than buying
one big computer you use one smaller
computer for most of the month when you
have low load and then we experience
higher loads you add a second computer
and you spread the load across them and
that's a very common kind of move that
aligns better with the cloud offering
and also works better for you or
costs we'll talk about that just a
moment and you can operate with order
called auto scaling group so instead of
you having to pay attention to the load
and you saying oh I'm getting higher
load let me spend something up which
becomes a human intervention operational
activity the cloud environment can say
i'm going to let i'm going to track this
and when the load gets at a certain
point on on one server I automatically
spend up another one and you might not
even be aware of it but it's a race to
do that you have to set up load
balancers and make automatic you know
design it for automatic connections and
that's part of redesigning your
application to line up the cloud
offerings so this is just two examples
around scaling and auto scaling but
there are many many ways that you can
say i'm going to redesign my application
to really align with the cloud offerings
and take advantage of the way they
operate and so forth the benefits you
find is one you can raise the resiliency
so if you've gone to that horizontal
scaling maybe you have redundancies that
a one large computer you're always
running two small ones if one of them
goes down your application is still up
and running it's not unavailable so you
can increase your application resiliency
you can be responsive to the dynamic I
didn't say that very clearly responsive
to dynamic application loads so that you
can your application can dynamically
adjust if you have unexpected or
periodic application loads you can maybe
reduce your cloud costs there's no costs
turning something off and then bring it
back up so that an example of you run
that report once a month or twice a
month it's very easy to during the off
time when you don't need that at that
server to be running with that
application available you can turn it
down and only bring it up and run and so
all of a sudden you can really change
your cost structure and you'll get
better application a better alignment of
the application with competitive needs
you know if you need to have the ability
to you know support very heavy loads
with caching you can take you can put
caching into your application is the
providers caching functionality and you
know that will help your application
so you can get better alignment of your
application with competitive needs there
are some challenges around this I don't
want to get sound like it's no you know
it sounds fantastic the question is you
know what does it take to do that well
you typically have to refactor your
application you have to examine is
design and say how can I better align
this with my app with my providers
environment how do I take better
advantage of that you may have to
redesign it refactor it split
functionality out in my great
functionality different servers or
different application packages so forth
and this inevitably requires greater
scoffs staff skills this isn't just like
I'm going to run virtualization but
instead of my environment or in the
cloud environment it's i'm going to
redesign my application i'm going to
make it look more like the cloud
environment that it runs in I'm going to
align it better you have to have more
Skills on staff you have to develop new
skills all right let's talk about the
next level which is really a very
dramatic reading of how you do things so
instead of I'm going to take the
application I've got and run it
unchanged or maybe change it enough to
be better aligned with the cloud
environment I'm going to rethink the way
I do business and this is really a very
exciting part of what's going on cloud
computing and something that's
increasingly an important part of the
way organizations are using cloud
environments and really the phrase I use
is this creates new applications to
compete in a software eating the world
environment and the person in the
picture in case you don't recognize him
is marc andreessen who was one of the
founders of Netscape which is was the
very first application browser company
really helped catalyze the internet age
and he's gone on and done various things
in he now runs corran's a venture
capital organization and is considered a
real visionary at about four years ago
he wrote an editorial for the wall
street journal where he said software is
eating the world the example he used is
or was things like travel agents you
know at one time if you wanted to take
an airplane flight somewhere you had to
call up a travel agency and they knew
all the stuff about getting you know
finding the flight and so forth those
days are disappeared right today if
you're going to take flight you do it
yourself use an application that the
carrier united or american or whatever
would be your local or favorite carrier
that they provide or you might use one
of the aggregators like Travelocity or
something like that that's just best
example he says he said really we've
started to see this accelerate and we're
seeing enormous change in the way the
organization's do business online the
way they engage with customers the way
that they interact with partners and so
forth so this is a sort of a you know
software eating the world environment
some examples of this are you know you
might have an application that you
provide your customers via retail
organization retail company they have
that running on their on their mobile
phone while they're in your store and
you can track you know did they spend a
lot of time in around sweaters and maybe
you can take that it insight about that
customer and start to interact with them
differently excuse me for a moment you
can
with them differently you can present
new offers to them you can learn more
about them and provide better value for
them or you might build an IOT
application you know internet of thing a
place of physical device you might
smarten a physical device that you
create and then transfer data from it
I'll just be an example that I I saw a
fellow who works in the global analytics
division of tetra pak and many of you
are probably for tetra pak they're sort
of the paper boxes that you can get
liquids in so you know in many parts of
the world milk is not purchased
refrigerated it's purchased in a sort of
cardboard II kind of a box that consider
in a shelf and be stable for a long time
so fascinating fascinating way they run
these things you know a lot of benefits
well they put analytics they started to
track the analytics of what was going on
with their box box making that goes on
the site on the on the customers premise
so if you're a dairy you would have a
tetra pak machine on your site and you
use that to sort of put your milk into
it so forth one of the things that they
were tracking was how long it took for a
cut to happen I want to cut the paper to
wrap it around the milk they would send
this back and analyze it and in the past
if a blade got dull what would happen is
it just stopped cutting the paper it
would be unsuccessful the milk wouldn't
the carton milk would start spilling all
over the dairy building a huge cleanup
activity and downtime for the dairy well
they started to track these analytics
and start to track how long the cut took
and what they found was that the cuts
are to be could take longer because the
blades were dollar they could track that
and then do a proactive array early
intervention to change that blade so
they wouldn't have those spills in that
downtime so that's just an example they
use this they smartened up their box
making device so they could get better
uptime and so forth so this is a kind of
an example of that sort of the benefits
are it offers new business opportunities
you know tetra pak is able to do things
with that and work better with its
customers you know makers it's
summers more profitable make them
happier race customer satisfaction so
forth it really reflects a new role for
i.t i.t used to be support the business
you know make sure the invoices go out
on time tell me you know how many how
much raw materials going on on on
premise now I tias run the business you
know if you're an airline and you can
interact with your customers online you
don't have an airline and you know this
is becoming a different role for IT and
you can use new application
architectures so-called microservices an
emerging architecture that really helps
you iterate applications more quickly
respond to customer demand new market
opportunities you can use these new
application architectures when you re
envision the way you do applications the
way you deploy them operate them I don't
know if I'd call this a drawback but
this definitely requires very
sophisticated cloud skills and you know
you you can't get there if you sort of
say I'm going to take somebody who knows
how to run virtual machines on premise
that's my new cloud architect you're not
going to get be able to develop this
kind of application you need to really
understand your cloud environments and
so forth so this is kind of the way you
can deploy applications here's kind of
the approach to this you know from a
business environment lifting shift is
very good for a stable environment but
rien visioning is really about
transforming business environment I
think most companies see themselves in a
transforming they feel like boy our
business environment is changing a lot
application changes you know lifting
shift is fine if you're only changing
once or twice a year but how many
businesses are in that environment they
want to be able to change much more
frequently once or twice a week which
you do refactoring and really get to
maybe constant once or twice a day I'm
going to add a new little changes new
functionality tweaks and I want to do
that as fast as often as I want to not
how often we're having we're scheduling
change management your cloud commitment
is different lipsticks shift relatively
low by the time you get to
re-envisioning your clogged commitment
is is complete you're really designing
and operating applications that can only
be running cloud environments
and likewise your cloud skills change
you can be relatively low with listen
shift you need to get to monitor too
high for refactoring and you get to need
to be at high or sophisticated with
Riaan visioning well I hope I've
convinced you that cloud computing is a
huge deal through those stats and I hope
I've you know sort of giving you a view
point about what you can do with
applications to make them align with
that new reality the question is how do
you build those cloud skills because
clearly they're going to be core if
you're going to get to forty percent of
your application portfolio writing and
cloud environments jumping into
seventy-five percent maybe in another
five years beyond that you clearly you
need to have oh you know your
organization needs to be staffed with
people who really understand cloud well
I want to say that organizational skill
is a journey not a destination right
scale is a company in the cloud space
that's been around for a long time it
helps manage applications they do a
survey each year of not just their
customers but people who are engaged
with cloud computing and they've done
this for years and traditionally the
biggest barrier to cloud adoption cited
by response was security people weren't
convinced the cloud was secure well this
year that change and now the largest
adoption area is lack of skills and
resources meaning that people are now
relatively comfortable with the security
that cloud environments provide there
and now they're confronting the next
thing okay I'm convinced clouds and a
big deal i want to start putting
applications there oh holy moly i don't
have all the skills on site in my
organization that I have now what I want
to say is that a common skill base is
critical and this isn't always
appreciated but if everybody is sort of
speak on the same sheet of paper this
leads to consistent application
architectures you don't get a situation
where one group designs application is
one way another group designs a
different way somebody takes advantage
of one service in one application
somebody use a different service in the
tenth one and then you end up with high
operational costs because you have to
have skills to run all these different
application architectures use all these
different services you're getting
different metric
different tooling that's very expensive
so if you use a comment have as common
skill base and common design patterns
you get much greater reusability you get
greater staff availability across things
because people can be cross trained and
it allowed for greater staff assignment
flexibility to do this to achieve this
common skill based education as a core
foundation so it ensures a common skill
base everyone knows the same information
everyone's gotten the same basic
patterns it trains the best practices so
you don't get something where somebody
says well I looked at a blog post like
and somebody said you should do it this
way so I'm going to do it that way well
you don't know if that person who wrote
that blog post is a genius or an idiot
and so you want to have the best
practices not just what's out there and
by using education you can train to the
best practices you can make sure that
you've got the best way to do things
being put in your organization
certifications streamline the skill
building you know the cloud providers
themselves put together curriculum and
say this is the best way to use our
application environment this is the best
services to use this is the best way to
design applications to take advantage of
our services and they put those
certifications out there well that
streamlines the process for you because
you don't have to figure out well what
are what are the best practices where do
I look to find the best way to do things
rely on the cob arrives to find that and
look to that and by using certifications
you can actually also bring skills in
you don't have to say you know I'm gated
by how fast I can get my own personnel
trained in addition to that I can look
to the outside and say look to external
people and say okay I want to I'll bring
you in do you have the right skill set
let me look to the certifications to
figure right out so certifications can
be a tremendous benefit around this what
kind of time frame do you have for these
enterprise skills well you know the
survey that I talked about earlier
indicates the enormous shift and
deployment patterns this is
a sea change in the way that I T is
going to be done diff forty percent of
your application can be grown earning in
the cloud environment by 2020 you know
what half of your staff has to be ready
a couple years before that because
you're going to be migrating your
applications are building new ones so
you can't wait till 2020 and say oh now
I better start training my people know
they have to be ready earlier so fifty
percent of your staff has to be clout
ready by 2018 and that means if you're
in IT management you have to have an
aggressive skill development plan plan
you can't sort of say I hope this will
come together or maybe around 2018 I'll
start thinking about this because it'll
be important no you have to start today
and sort of say what is my roadmap for
developing the skills within my
organization whether I do internal
training whether I bring people in from
the outside or as most likely i'm going
to do both how am I know about that how
am I going to ensure that i have the
right skills in place how am i going to
do that so having an aggressive skill
development plan really critical what's
the road map for that well one is you
can rely on self-study you know you can
sort of hand out books to your
organization or you can direct them
toward youtube or the universal solution
for everything is I'll google it well
you know all those things are valuable
resources but what can happen is that
you end up with inconsistent skills
right one person finds one YouTube video
and says down oh that looks great that's
what I'm gonna do it a second person
does it google may find a different
solution on somebody's blog and your
back to that situation where one group
designs at one way another group designs
it another way they use different
services so forth you could go to
traditional IT training and i've been
involved with official IT training both
as a student and as an instructor and
you know there are some real benefits to
it but it's you know i'm talking about
sort of you know go to this site sit in
a classroom there'll be somebody
standing up in the front it'll be done
monday through friday monday through
thursday on these dates well that's
fantastic if you can get free those days
if the people you need are available if
you
get them to that location so you know
some real drawbacks that online training
is an emerging field and one that I
believe in very strongly and that's one
of the reasons that I was drawn towards
simply learn I believe that online
training is the future of the way that
training is going to be done and really
it's the only one of these solutions
that scales and so it's going to be very
important as you think about your
roadmap going forward so the solution
must provide a common skill base I
realize I'd really hammered on this but
I think this is really critical you know
having your organization using a common
having a comet analytical framework
having a common language using the same
design patterns having the same outlook
I think it's really important it the
solution has your training solution your
skill solution has the skill to meet
aggressive timeframes it can't be what
we can put you know three percent of our
staff through this year and another six
percent next year that's not going to
get you where you need to be it has to
teach best practices not just any
practices it has to align with how
students want to learn you know it's a
cliche but today people want to want to
work and learn the way they in their
business environments the way they do in
their personal environments and you know
that means I want to do stuff online I
want to do it in my own time frame if I
want to do it at 10 at night that's what
I want to do it if I want to you know do
it in 20 minute chunks that's the way I
want to do it so your education offering
should really align with how students
want to learn and you know my
perspective is really online is going to
be the way that's accomplished so in
conclusion well for sure you want to
avoid what you see on the right hand
side here you know oh I'm giving you an
excuse to cloud ate my homework I didn't
get it done you know I wasn't ready you
know we have this application that we
can't it's absolutely [ __ ] you know
critical the way we're going to engage
with customers going forward oh I can't
really do anything about it till the
middle of next year because I don't have
the infrastructure so cloud computing is
the future of IT
has the fastest adoption rate in history
and there's no sign that it's slowing
down gaining value requires climbing the
deployment pattern remember that sort of
lifting shift all through rien vision
the more value that you want to get out
of IT the more value that businesses
demand for my team the more you have to
be able to climb that deployment pattern
ladder and really remember software is
eating the world if your honor this is
the best time ever to be an IT but in
senseless most challenging as well
because we're in a software is eating
the world environment and if you work in
IT your business going to turn to you
and say okay how do I operate here how
do I compete your training solution has
to align with your deployment plans a
solution that says I can get all my
people trained by 2024 isn't going to
cut it you need to build necessary
consistent skills and that will help you
avoid lame excuses as we have here in
this loud in this car too so with that
we have time for questions and so chip
do we have any questions fantastic yes
we do we've got a few questions queued
up here that we're going to jump on here
really quickly thank you for that
presentation I I think that you
absolutely have made the case for the
growth of the opportunity and the need
for people and organizations to plan
ahead so we do have some questions here
but before we do that i'm going to ask
everybody to indulge me for about 60
seconds while i take over the screen i'm
going to launch a little poll here and
give you the opportunity to reach out to
simply learn to learn more about the
training that we offer it's important to
understand that this webinar is a
public-facing webinar we've invited
Bernardo here to to share this
information with you and we have folks
on here who have joined us who are
already familiar with simply learn and
perhaps are taking training with us and
we have some folks on here who perhaps
only know about us by hearing about this
webinar from a friend or seeing a social
posting and enjoined us to hear what
what we had to share but it's it's
important for you to understand that
what we do beyond
the webinars is that we are a business
and technology training provider we have
over 400 web-based training courses in a
spectrum of professional skill sets
obviously including cloud but also
across project management and big data
and digital marketing and lots and lots
of different business critical skill
sets and we have over 400 of those
web-based training courses and these are
accredited most of them by more than 40
third-party certifying bodies like like
Prince to and PMI and apmg in the open
group and X in and so forth so these
trainings are designed to bring your
skill set up to where it needs to be to
tackle the exam certification exams from
these organizations and secure your very
valuable professional certification to
make yourself more effective and and
more desirable in this very competitive
job market all of these courses of
course are designed and presented by our
faculty of very experienced and
professional trainers like Bernard
himself when you join these training
programs what you get is structured
courses with a variety of different
learning styles some folks learn better
on their own time at ten thirty at night
watching a video other folks like to
have you know a little more direct
one-on-one sort of interaction and we do
have some courses that are available
where folks can interact directly with a
live faculty member at specific times of
the day again virtually online from
wherever it's convenient for you to do
so so it fits your lifestyle and it fits
your availability you'll get lab
exercises you'll get simulation exams in
some cases you'll get in where it's
necessary perhaps access to additional
platforms and software to run
experiments and do practice projects and
you get access to our moderated forums
as well so you can interact with our
faculty and with other students all that
said if you want to learn more took the
appropriate box we'll have someone get
in touch with you there's no obligation
but we can show you how the learning
platform works and we can help you
choose the right Learning Path to meet
your goals all right that's my
contractual obligation to make sure you
know what it is that we do here I'm
going to close that will be
Bernard screen here again real quick any
second now there we go go to webinars a
little bit slow to keep up with me but
it's coming back so Bernard just so you
know we are seeing your screen if you
need to surf around when you're
answering any of these questions feel
free to do so so we'll jump into the
questions and I'll tackle the first one
because it's the most common when will
the webinar or slide deck be available
are you recording this and the answer is
yes all of our webinars are recorded
most of them are cleaned up and edited
and produced and put into the simply
learn website for folks to see and very
often they're also added to the simply
learn youtube channel so if you have not
gone there and subscribed already I
would recommend that you do so all right
first question from Vivek this goes back
a little while early in your
presentation you were speaking about the
growth of cloud through 2020 and beyond
just want to clarify whether that was
specific to any one particular platform
or whether that was really just
industry-wide we're going to see that
growth rate the question was posed as
what proportion of your applications
will be in a public cloud provider so it
was not directed toward any particular
cloud provider and so you know that was
that was a question designed to discern
the intent of end users without trying
to understand their plans for particular
cloud providers or something like that
and that's why I sort of discussed it as
what does apply generally not you know
you need this you know you need AWS
skills or add your skills or whatever it
might be just you know this is a trend
going on in the industry hope that
answers your question if not you can do
a follow-up question yes I imagine it
probably does but yeah Vivek if you need
more specifics go ahead and ask another
question with us Terry is asking on the
project manager what kind of technical
skills do i need to to bring along to
start learning about cloud technology
how would you see the relationship
between the project management skills
Terry probably already has in place
what can he add to that to make himself
a competitive in the cloud industry well
I would answer the question in a couple
of ways one I i think a it depends sorry
i'm not being very good let me back up
project managers sometimes have come out
of a technical background sometimes come
out of you know a different kind of
background and if you have a technical
background i recommend taking a sort of
a foundation cloud computing course like
you know simply aaron has a solutions
architect associate course for AWS if
you're if that's the environment going
to be choosing or the equivalent in one
of the other environments these are
technical but they're not you know sort
of i'm going to teach you how to split
the atom kind of technical and you know
those are good introductions for that
and you know that's that's a good way to
go about it as a more general sort of
you know what is con computing what are
the trends what are they you know facial
so forth um i guess it's a bit
self-serving but you might take a look
at the blog that i have up on cio calm
and i often discuss you know cloud
computing trends adoption the
implications for IT organizations not on
a technical level but more on an
organizational level what does this
imply from the way that I T is going to
do its business support and you might
find that those are helpful so a
foundation course or perhaps reading in
an area that sort of discusses what does
this imply for the way that we design
you know develop applications next
question I think that's perfect yeah I
hope that helps Terry Devon she has a
general question
yes hello any recommendations for what
the industry opportunity looks like
particularly in that region of the world
and any any particular certification
certifying body that might be most
appropriate for that region I'm sorry
chip at least for me your voice your
audio dropped out right after you said
the person's name and you know has a
question about and then it just went
silent for a minute could you repeat the
question sure let me just double check
are you hearing me now I hear you now
fantastic must have have a little drop
out there sorry about that thank you go
to webinar he's saying that he sees
himself as a relative early starter in
the cloud industry and he is in India
and he does have experience in AWS i'm
not sure doesn't you whether or not you
are certified in AWS vide has experience
in the AWS curious to know any insights
you might have about really establishing
yourself in the industry are there any
particular certification certifying
bodies that are more recognized in india
than elsewhere is there anything unique
about that region well so I'm freer with
with apmg which has a very broad range
of certifications there are some of the
certifications that thats employer has
and then there's certifications that are
vendor specific like the AWS and so
forth what I can say is that without
coming about particular certifying
bodies you know I would look for ones
that are that have adoption throughout
the world that have at least within the
apmg world or the apmg in the ecosystem
those are referred to as accredited
training organizations and you know I'm
sure that the other bodies have their
equivalent and I would look for
certifications that are really accepted
globally that would be my recommendation
about that i would also very slow
look at certifications that emanate from
the particular vendors and you know in
particular AWS because you said you were
with interview us already awss is opened
up a india-based region so they provide
services directly from India to the
Indian market and you know I belief
about in particular for India and China
that a good model for what's going to
happen with computing is mobile phones
or tell telephony telecommunications you
know in the u.s. you know we invented
the telephone so we have this you know
tremendous legacy of wired telephones
copper telephones plain old telephone
service well emerging economies when it
came time for telephony just jump
straight to mobile because mobile is
available requires a lot less
infrastructure development it's more
cost effective and so forth I think
we're going to see the same thing with
computing as these economies of
developing nations like India China
become more computing intensive they're
not going to go through the stage of
well we need to build our own data
centers you know we're gonna we're going
to have our own tin now they'll just use
somebody else just like they the mobile
telephony so I think getting
certifications around specific providers
it's a good strategy that I would
recommend because I think there's going
to be tremendous growth for those cloud
providers within those within within
developing economies generally and India
specifically it sounds like very good
advice to me I hope that helps better to
give you a little a little direction
there we've got a couple of questions
from folks that are that are a little
bit overlapping here they're kind of
asking somewhat the same questions and
and you know you you've addressed some
of it in your presentation but the
questions are basically they're what
they're saying is you know I've got
cloud sales but I don't have a technical
background or I've been in the service
industry for 20 years but I want a
better idea of how I can grow you know
in a way that I can expand my expertise
well while still maintaining my my place
in my market what are the are the best
recommendations for moving forward the
path if you will the career path of
moving from one tangentially related
career path and increasing my viability
in the cloud industry so would you say
that folks like this they've got some
some a little bit of technical
background or or what have you and they
want to grow in the direction of cloud
and be viable in that space should they
focus on certifications first should
they focus on getting an opportunity for
some hands-on real-world projects is
there a balance there what's the best
path for them well you know I guess
maybe just fully supports simpler but I
think if you're a salesperson and you're
planning to be a salesperson for your
career I don't know that you know sort
of getting a technical certification is
the best way to go about that amazon
does have a very strong partner
ecosystem and i believe that they
actually have certifications that are
revolving around around those kinds of
things and certainly you know looking to
you know you sort of want to be in the
in an organization aligned with this
with this greater trade so we talked to
primarily about technical stuff but
really this is going to affect every
part of the IT ecosystem so if you are a
consulting company you need to be a
cloud computing consulting company if
you're a system integrator you need to
be a cloud suspect reader if you were a
partner company you need to be a club
partner company so you know there's
tremendous opportunities you know you
know throughout the ecosystem and you
know you should I would suggest that you
know look for certifications or or
something that align with what you do
you know I think that having some
technical background is is is extremely
useful but I wouldn't necessarily
look toward you know I'm going to go get
a solution architect you know advanced
certification so i can go sell um and I
hope that's that's helpful and I hope
that addresses the question chip that
was being put forward I think it does
yeah yeah I am that again I had a couple
of folks here who had some some
similarly related questions and I hope
that does help I think you're right you
know you're looking for the the way to
make it sort of relevant to whatever you
are already working in and really maybe
the core for some folks if they're not
going to be working in cloud directly as
a cloud professional but they're going
to be tangentially related to it in
sales or some other way foundational
training and familiarity with it thus to
the point at which you're sharing a
vocabulary and you can speak
intelligently about it with stakeholders
but you aren't necessarily going to be
the implementation person is where the
value is going to land is does that seem
reasonable yes I would say that's a good
plan all right let's see we are up
against the hour already I'm hoping if
you're okay we can maybe go one or two
minutes longer and try to hit one or two
more questions really quick sure you got
time terrific ragavendra is is saying
that he's been in up sorry no that's one
of the ones that I already tried to
address with you here a moment ago by
compiling them together here we go a
tool how is the cloud industry
compatible and secure based on HIPAA
regulations there have been lots of
changes in the medical domain are there
any specific services or direction that
you see happening in cloud that are
specific to the medical domain that
might be useful for medical
documentation and software that makes
sense well I you know a big question
that you know and
around cloud computing is often a
characterized as security but the
question really oftentimes is about
compliance and HIPAA is a compliance
regimen you know if it has some security
aspects but also has other aspects well
and HIPAA is just a well-known example
of the kinds of compliance things oh and
obviously compliance compliance
regiments can be challenging i will say
that organizations have successfully
done implemented HIPAA compliant
applications within amazon for sure and
i'm sure this case for azure as well so
it's you know many people assume oh
these can't be accomplished these
regiments can't be accomplished in a
external environment or a public cloud
environment that's not really the case
oftentimes one of the things that people
often have to recognize though is with
compliance this is true about security
is it's not all just on the provider
there are actions or activities or score
processes that the user has to take as
well and so this can't simply be a
question of is the is a provider HIPAA
compliant it's if working together me
and the provider can we jointly deliver
a solution that is HIPAA compliant hippo
being the example in this case and the
answer is yes but it's not a simple you
know I just I set this you know tick
this checkbox in the configuration in
the cloud environment now magically it's
HIPAA compliant that makes perfect sense
absolutely you need to be able to
examine it and so forth but it is
possible and you know really requires
examination and in understanding what
the requirements are of being compliant
with a particular Richmond perfect thank
you for that I hope that answers the
question will complete these last two
questions there a little bit related if
just knock them out real quick and then
we'll be all done vivek is asking about
X and cloud certifications as opposed to
apmg if you have any insight there about
maybe their acceptability and relevance
in the industry whether or not they're
looking for different things to gain the
certification and zoom is asking about
if you have any insight into
certifications relating specifically to
cloud security and risk management uh
yes so the I I confess I'm not familiar
with Exim I am familiar with apmg and so
I you know and and the reason I was
comfortable working with apmg is because
they are they do a wide range
certifications they're a global
organization highly respected so I can't
really speak to Exim and in terms of
what would be considered most desirable
and so forth in terms of I'm sorry what
was the second part of that question it
completes my mind chip have I lost you
I'm so sorry i I'm GoToWebinar is giving
me a little drop out here I apologize I
see this last question is if there are
any specific certifications regarding
security and risk management in cloud or
does the the general certifications for
cloud inclusive of security and risk
management issues well so the there's
two parts that answer so the for example
the aid of their certifications
definitely have an element of security
in them no question they're one of the
domains so it's addressed the
certification you receive however
doesn't say sort of security it says
solution architect associate or whatever
it might be so it definitely address the
security and what the best practices are
and so forth the sort of surprisingly
there aren't really cloud security
certification
given that it's such a topic that is you
know been such such so high-profile as I
mentioned there is an organization
called the cloud security alliance they
have what I would call a rudimentary or
foundational security certification
called the CCS k I think it's cloud
computing security knowledge i think is
what it stands for and that's widely
known and and recognized I wouldn't
necessarily say oh that indicate holding
that indicates a tremendously
sophisticated level of security
knowledge you know it probably addresses
things like you know compliance but it
doesn't you know so I say oh now I'm
certified to be to really understand
HIPAA I don't think it makes sense that
you know it's an interesting thing that
there aren't those certifications given
that it's such a high-profile thing but
there I would say that that's not
something that you can go seek out and
find and get a certification around
that's maybe unfortunately but that's
the state of affairs today it may grow
out of the evolution of the industry
though so we'll keep our eye on it for
those of you who are still with us we
are running a little bit long and and
that'll be it for the Q&A now that I
want to let you know check real quick in
your chat module those of you who are
still with us I have shared a few links
in there including a link to SAP cloud
security alliance and then some other
links that will direct you towards some
other resources there is a link there to
the simply learn courses on
virtualization and cloud computing there
are some links to some articles and
resources on the simply learn site as
well as apmg an article there actually
by Bernard that I'm pointing you at and
then to Bernards articles on cio.com and
lastly a link to other upcoming webinars
and resources organized by specialty
from simply learn so a few little links
there for you to click get them open now
while you can while we're still on the
on the call because I'm going to be
shutting us down here in just a moment
but you'll have them open in your
browser and you can continue to to look
around so with that said yeah we've got
a few minutes long but it was
great to have all these questions from
everybody Bernard it was a pleasure
working with you for the first time sir
thanks for all your insights well thank
you for the invitation to speak I really
enjoyed it absolutely and we'll do it
again I'm sure and to everybody else
thank you all so much for taking time
out of your days to join us wherever you
are again if it's the middle of your
workday or if you'd stayed up super late
to join us when you should be asleep we
appreciate your dedication and taking
the time out of your lives to join up
with us here join us again for future
webinars on that link that I provided
and until then have a terrific rest of
your day and we will see you next time
cheers bye bye
you